Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians.
Good morning.
Thank you for joining us for our 41st episode!
BAU BAU!
Our 41st episode and 101st stream.
Still lots of stuff to do!
Ruffians, in case maybe you forgot.
Oh, we definitely forgot.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO Live!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Ruffians, are you ready?
You awake?
Ready to BAU BAU?
A brand new day.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
And with that, the morning starts.
It starts.
The day starts.
Whether you want it to or not.
It just does.
But again today, I think a Ruffian has had another peron sighting!
Hopefully it's not too scary.
Let's see this time.
October there was a lot of those, but... Not this time.
What?
De-den!
There's a lot of powerful energy coming from this Pero Sighting.
It's cool, but I'm somehow a bit frightened.
You know Gunpla use a pretty small scale, but somehow it's really hard to tell just how big it is from this photo.
I feel like it almost makes Pero look like, huge, nice.
Did Pero feel a bit threatened and want to get a Gundam to use to intimidate others or something?
Intimidation.
That's his tactic.
I mean, it makes sense.
Pero can look pretty cute and harmless at first glance.
So, I guess I can understand, but...
This Gundam looks a bit different from the others.
To tell the truth, Ruffians, we know very, very, very little about Gundam.
We watch Suisei no Majou, you know, the Witch of Mercury, but even then,
We had a little bit of a hard time following along.
I don't know, I just didn't feel smart enough to understand sometimes.
It was really good though, but I just didn't own it.
I thought it was good, apparently it's not.
I'm sorry.
Hopefully Pero didn't cause too much mischief though, okay?
BAU BAU!
I like to build gunpla.
Yeah, I like that.
No more.
Wow, Ruffians.
I mentioned that today is the 101st day of FUWAMOCO.
But in case you didn't know, yesterday was our 100th day together!
BAU BAU!
That makes today our
Our 101st day as members of hololive!
I wanted to mention again, you know, yesterday was our big celebration of 101 days since our debut.
No, yesterday was our celebration of 100.
100 days!
100 days since debut!
It was not just that.
It was also 100 days continuously streaming every day!
And those days being scheduled in advance, you know?
Being on time, too.
Perfect attendance.
That can be tricky sometimes, you know?
Ruffians!
If you were a teacher, what grade would you give us?
Teacher Ruffians.
I'm reading!
S+, is that good?
A+, 100!
Yeah!
Well, you know, it was a really special 100 days filled with lots of memories.
And we hope that it's a little bit of a snapshot into the rest of our days that are ahead of us for many years to come.
Just a snapshot, right?
But I guess now that it's been 100 days, you'd probably like to see what our room looks like too, huh?
Not just the studio.
Maybe.
Well, we'll have to see!
Who knows?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your love, your warmth, and support!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Here's to many, many more days, okay?
Yeah, many, many more days.
Doing our celebration.
It wasn't just chit-chat.
We also brought a mirror out so that you could finally see what you really look like.
Not just, like, rough scribbles from us.
Wow.
What do you think?
How do you look, Ruffians?
Yeah, we have two different designs.
Originally by each of us, you know.
Moco-chan with the pink, the cool looking Ruffian.
And mine, the silly and cute blue Ruffian.
These are just the official looks though, so Ruffians, if you feel like you're neither or maybe a mix of both, please feel free to design and draw a Ruffian a bit more suitable for yourself, okay?
This is just like the, maybe the majority of Ruffians official designs.
Thank you so much to Oriente for the super cute finished designs and for making them come to life too.
Right!
Thank you!
Ruffians!
Are you excited now that you know exactly what you look like?
Pussies!
You want pussies!
Is a mohawk necessary?
Yeah.
I guess you could have a different hairstyle if you really wanted.
Yeah!
But I don't know, it makes you look cooler, no?
Magnets!
Mhmm.
That'll be fun.
Every time you walk by, you can look at it and like, touch the nose.
We really like magnets.
That's all.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We look forward to seeing more of you Ruffians.
I know.
Yesterday was a very special day, right?
But it wasn't just our special day.
It was actually not even our special day.
It was special, but it wasn't that special.
Yesterday was actually hololive Indonesia's Zetta-senpai's birthday!
Zetta-senpai, happy birthday!
And, Ruffians, did you notice?
We're actually guests on her birthday too!
You know, Zetta-senpai asked us what we'd do if our birthday- If it was her birthday and we got stuck in a time loop.
And what we would do if we woke up in her body.
Just ignore Fuwawa's answer in particular for that doukei.
Mai, I feel like if our birthday was stuck in a loop, we'd just be this type of people who celebrate their birthdays for the whole month.
I don't know.
I think it's just silly.
You know, a birthday is special because it's that single special day.
One day.
You know what?
If you celebrate for the whole month, that's just an excuse to spend one twelfth of the year partying, okay?
It has to be that one special day.
One day for Mococo and one day for Fuwawa, okay?
Not a whole month.
But you know, I think it's important to celebrate a special day when it's special.
It is!
We're very sentimental, you know that.
I would like to see Zetta-senpai keep talking so chill.
It's important.
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday, Zetta-senpai!
Hi!
Well, Ruffians, you remember what I said on Monday, right?
What did you say on Monday?
You say a lot of things.
On Monday, did I say FUWAMOCO Morning right?
We had no misunderstandings.
Oh.
Yeah.
And, you know, Ruffians, I was a little bit concerned because I thought, you know, maybe, maybe, there's a little bit of a feeling that that might have been not correct.
Yeah, we thought we were good, but... Ruffians, why didn't you say anything?
Huh?
You didn't say a thing.
Yeah.
Was it because you were trying to be nice?
It seems, you know, Ruffians, that there was a misunderstanding left over from during Donkey Kong Country.
Ruffians, do you remember being as shocked as I was when you heard Moco-chan give a sudden, intense compliment to Donkey Kong out of nowhere?
I didn't!
Yeah, I didn't.
I was shocked.
Yeah, but Moco-chan, what did you say, huh?
It's a misunderstanding, okay?
All I said was that... You're gonna make me repeat it.
I said, Donkey Kong is really hot, huh?
But I meant the game, okay?
It was not a compliment to Donkey Kong.
We get really hot while playing the game.
And at the time, I thought all of you were being crazy.
And I still think that, but when I listen to it over,
I guess I could hear her.
But Ruffians!
First of all, why would you think that I would be a puppy that would say something like that?
Hai.
I'm Mococo.
We spent a hundred days together.
You should know me better than that.
Hai.
I'm not that kind of person.
Maybe that's a Nerissa thing.
Or maybe a Shiori thing.
But it's not a Mococo thing!
I obviously meant the game, okay?
Donkey Kong is very hot because it makes us hot while playing it.
Lots of screaming.
Very scary.
Falling.
Screaming.
Bananas.
Understand, okay?
Yeah.
Got it.
Not judging.
Are you sure?
You just threw Nerissa in the bus.
I'm sure.
I'm sure she likes Donkey Kong.
Yeah.
She likes Donkey Kong too, but not like that.
Not like that.
Not like Nerissa does.
BAU BAU!
Understood now, right?
You understand now, right?
Please don't misunderstand.
Moco-chan wasn't giving any weird compliments.
No!
I was just saying that it's hot.
Playing Donkey Kong.
Ruffian!
I had another dream.
Two days in a row!
And this one.
It was really unexpected, but a happy dream.
That's good.
Yeah.
I don't know, maybe it's because it's getting colder out now, and I feel really chilly in bed sometimes.
I felt really chilly this morning too.
But, you know what?
Ruffians, I think because of that, that's why I had a dream where it was really snowy.
Ruffians!
I was going sledding, and you were all pulling the sled through the snow for me!
And you know when I looked out, I could see all of you right in front, running like BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU.
And you were all glowing and shining!
Glowing Ruffians.
Yeah.
I don't know where we are going though, but...
I was just, I was really excited and I felt really warm too.
But all I could see was in the front, like in front of me, so you Ruffians.
And then a little bit to what was like the side.
That makes sense.
That's how vision works.
Yeah, I guess.
But it was just all white snow.
Yeah, and we were going really, really fast.
And I didn't know why.
Why?
Why so fast?
Yeah.
Because you're on a sled!
And even though you know, like, well, sometimes you can go slow on the sled too, right?
I don't know.
Even though we were going really fast, I didn't know where we were going, and it's cold and stuff too.
I was really comfy.
That's good.
But I was a bit annoyed though, because for some reason you couldn't hear me.
And so then we couldn't really talk that well together.
No communication.
No.
And then... Ruffians, you're all pretty small dogs.
Small dogs, but they're fast.
There was a lot of Ruffians though, but you know, not the usual slight dogs.
It was a little silly, like toy dogs.
Toy dogs!
But it was cute because I could see you all doing your best and working together as a team.
I'm not a chihuahua!
Not a chihuahua!
But that was my dream!
A bit strange, but a happy one.
Makes sense.
Toy Ruffians.
I'm happy to share another dream with you Ruffians!
I'm happy that it's better than my dreams recently!
We are... We are... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we saw you talking a bit about this yesterday.
And, uh, so we thought that maybe we should share something, but I don't know, it's a little bit embarrassing.
I don't know, it is.
I don't know why, but... You know, I think it came up in the 100 day stream yesterday, right?
But, Ruffians, when we were just tiny, tiny baby puppers, there was a show that we always watched with Mococo-B.
And it was a show that was really special to her.
It was her favorite... Star Trek!
Yeah, you know...
So, it was really special, so she shared it with us when we were still really little.
We don't really remember much, but our favorite part was about the fluffy and fuzzy tribbles.
Yeah, the tribbles everywhere.
She even gave us a plushie of them as a present.
Yeah, and a shake.
I'm excited.
Yeah, but we also did watch Star Wars a lot, too.
Yeah, and that's what we liked the best there.
Yeah, we like the Fluffy and the Fuzzy Ewoks the most.
Do you understand, Ruffians?
I wonder why, huh?
Yeah, but Mama Puppy likes Star Trek better, and Papa Puppy likes Star Wars better.
But I think maybe between the both of them, the Abyssgard household
Probably a Star Trek household.
Probably.
Yeah.
But no fights between Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy.
They agree to disagree.
Right.
Yeah.
I feel envy.
Speaking of Yamato!
No, this is Star Trek.
This is Star Trek, this is Star Wars.
Not Yamato, no!
Not Yamato!
No, it's good!
I thought that too.
There's a limit, okay?
Imagine it's not the Yamato, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's a little bit embarrassing, but... Yeah, that's a little bit of a view into the Abyssgard household.
I guess... I thought... Maybe...
Invite both some Ruffian spirits today.
So... So... I wanted to say something!
Good morning!
You're awake!
Your eyes are barely open, but you're awake!
Good morning sleepyhead!
You know, that's the thing.
Even though your eyes aren't totally open, even though you're not totally awake, what matters is that you are up and you're here now.
Sure, you might not be at your 100%, but that's okay!
You can't give 100% to everything you do, okay?
So for now, being only 50% awake is fine.
The important thing is that task, wake up, it's done!
Give yourself credit for that first step, okay?
And from here out, all the next steps of your day is going to be even easier!
If it's okay... Can I give you a tiny extra task for today?
I think it would be nice, so...
If it's okay.
Extra task!
Okay.
As you go about your day today, can you try to find one thing, just one thing that stands out to you and makes you happy?
It can be anything, okay?
For example, I talked about it, but when we went on a walk the other day, I was happy to see the one plant growing straight through the concrete, as if nothing was in its way, right?
Do something silly like that to remember the day by.
You can do it!
Okay!
Be the plant that I saw yesterday!
Let's make today a special one and be kind to ourselves.
You can do it!
You can get through to the weekend!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Got it!
Got it, Ruffians!
Moco-chan, you're giving homework now too?
Homework for the Ruffians as we work on our homework, huh?
Exactly!
You know what I'm looking forward to today?
What?
Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is this old man, Dino!
Dino's 13, you know?
He doesn't look 13.
He doesn't, right?
He's very wise, but you know he isn't great or anything.
Maybe... Is he going to get his fur dyed, maybe?
That's okay.
No shame.
Yeah, but you know... He just looks like he appreciates the world around him so much.
He does!
Yeah, you know... You know, all those walks you go on together... The ducks quacking and being annoying and squashing... I appreciate them too.
All those things, yeah.
It's a good way to view the world, you know?
Well, how does dino BAU BAU?
I feel like it's a surprisingly cute BAU BAU.
Really?
I feel like it's very quiet.
Doesn't need to be loud.
I feel like BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
It's a BAU BAU with a lot of wisdom behind it.
Yeah, softness.
Doesn't need attention.
Yeah.
Very kind.
Well, you know, Dino, yeah, Dino's very kind.
Enjoys life and the world around him.
Thirteen years of wisdom is what's behind all that fluff and fuzz.
Yeah, and he's just happy to be by your side, and most importantly, part of your world, too.
Yeah, no matter how old he is or how great he might get from here on, especially when the dye starts to run out.
I'm happy to be loved by you so much and to be able to spend lots of time with you.
BAU BAU!
13 years is amazing.
Lots of special memories.
Well, Ruffians, you've been walking those paws.
Where did you go this time?
Let's see!
De-den!
Squirrel!
Look at those ears!
Oh my gosh.
Ah, this is the best part of vlogs.
You know, seeing things like squirrels and other cool things.
Right, right.
It's a good poodle.
Right, it's a good poodle.
It must have been really hard to get it too.
And fast.
Yeah, but his ears are so long.
Right?
That's what I noticed first.
Longer than mine too.
They stand right up.
Well, I hope he can get really fat really soon.
Yeah.
She'll work on it.
But you know, you're lucky that he's the type of squirrel to run away from you, though.
To not run away?
No, to run away.
Oh, really?
Yeah, because we seem to have the opposite problem of us having to run away from the squirrels because they always are pretty aggressive.
Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe they see our ears and our tails and something awakens in them.
I don't know, but I just don't want to get shaken up by a squirrel for the snacks, okay?
You don't have it.
It's embarrassing running away from them.
I try to keep my distance.
I'm not distracted.
Ruffians, make sure that you get really warm.
Stay warm and cold when you go out, okay?
Be safe, okay?
You gotta be the fat squirrel too, okay?
Bundle up.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we received another question!
Today, our Question of the Day is... Hello FUWAMOCO!
I wanted to thank you for making these last few months enjoyable to go through.
Thank you!
Thank you for being a wonderful...
A wonderful part of our everyday, you know?
Your streams are always the best part of my day.
It always brightens my mood.
Anyways!
I have an important question to ask, right?
The question.
What's the color of your... Excuse me.
Excuse me?
What are you thinking?
Just because it's been 100 days doesn't mean that you can ask those kinds of questions ever, okay?
And you think that we'd actually answer it?
You'd think that?
We aren't the kind of dogs to do that and this is a morning show!
It's a morning show!
You know, we said maybe that we show you our room.
But don't just think you can get away with asking stuff like this because maybe we're just a bit closer now, okay?
Okay, Ruffians?
You got it!
Ruffians... So that's... That's what you really like, huh?
That's what you think of us, huh?
My opinion has changed.
BAU BAU.
Well, I guess we should let them know what's coming next, Moco-chan.
Should we?
Should we even?
Oh, and I guess we're looking for more questions if there are... Not questions like that!
Morning show questions, Ruffians!
Morning show questions!
This is a morning show!
But Kiara-senpai asked... No!
No!
This is a morning show!
It wasn't good then either.
Ruffians.
Sometimes you need to be softer.
Well, I guess we're looking for more questions.
And, uh... Pero Sightings and your dogs too.
At least for now.
This is a morning show, so that's the sort of things that we have on a morning show, you know?
Yeah.
I guess you could submit them with the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
If you'd like to.
If you think you can be up to the task.
If you can handle that!
Yeah.
Well, Moco-chan, let's share what's next then.
Our next stream coming up is... De-den!
Well, this isn't today.
Tonight we're gonna be taking the evening to focus on some of our homework.
But we'll be back tomorrow for Fall Guys together with the Doggy Pack.
That's okay, right, Moco-chan?
Maybe that's okay.
Together with the Doggy Pack.
You know, it was so much fun last time, right?
It was.
You know?
Yeah, so...
Ruffians, you know, if you weren't able to join, please grab Fall Guys, it's free!
And then that way we can play all together!
If you feel like it, I guess.
It'd be a perfect time to grab the game and maybe if you're not part of the Doggy Pack yet, you could join and then, right?
We can have some really chaotic and silly times all together tomorrow!
Chaotic and silly in Fall Guys, not like the last question.
Yeah.
We'll see you then, okay, Ruffians?
Maybe.
And we also have a recommendation, you know, since we're not gonna be live tonight.
We recommend our most recent archive of our
I keep talking and nobody explodes steam.
I think, you know, what really stands out here is you can see just how well we worked together to smoothly defuse bombs, right?
We did a good job.
We almost didn't need to say anything, right?
Right?
Exactly like that.
No chaos.
No yelling.
No anger.
Nothing.
BAU BAU!
Do the homework!
Do the homework that we haven't been able to do.
So that we can do some really cool things in the future too.
Put Money-chan's tears back into the eye socket.
Yeah.
Right back.
Right with these paws.
Yeah.
So, but!
You know we have some really exciting things.
We have a watch-along with all of Advent.
A rebroadcast of our Rawr Camp.
We're finding it also short too!
I would hope that the Ruffians are well behaved for the watch-along.
I think so.
Maybe.
As long as you're not gonna ask Barbie any inappropriate questions either, huh?
Right.
Yeah.
Yup.
Well, Ruffians, thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning.
Our 41st FUWAMOCO Morning on our 101st day in hololive.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you.
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Shiki.
BAU BAU!
Choco Milk Tea.
The One Nerd.
BAU BAU!
Sharon.
Dust Temple.
BAU BAU!
Tuna Salad.
Captain Spy.
BAU BAU!
Yulius.
Cruise.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!